the days that I had here cheers with
them they're the best days of my life
Kirsty alley has died at 71 years old
[Music]
I shook up my life a lot because you
know I sort of had hit every the good
news and the bad news I had hit every
goal I wanted to hit for the all the
things I want to accomplish in the
second half of my life I needed the
energy so that's been the most
successful thing for me the actresses
children true and Lily Parker confirmed
the news on Twitter revealing Kirsty
died after a short battle with cancer
quote she was surrounded by her closest
family and fought with great strength
leaving us with a certainty of her
never-ending Joy of living and whatever
Adventures lie ahead as iconic as she
was on screen she was an even more
amazing mother and grandmother I seem to
fall into shows before I started them
off and it's it's been good you know
it's been good in in my career they went
on to praise their mother's zest and
passion for life and her Eternal Joy of
creating I just have a new baby Lily
price that's the best thing that ever
happened to me that's wonderful Lily
remembered her late Mother by sharing
this photo on Instagram the fun with
Kirsty
we had a blast I mean honestly
we we loved working together kirsty's
good friend and former co-star John
Travolta paid tribute to the actress on
social media saying quote Kirsty was one
of the most special relationships I've
ever had I love you Kirsty I know we
will see each other again
Kirsty Rose to Fame in the 80s when she
starred as Rebecca Howe on NBC's cheers
Miss Rebecca Howe Sam Malone Sam Rebecca
Howe how do you do
taboo
and to you I could never remember my
lines my lines were written if you saw
the Cheers Bar my I used to carry a uh a
cigar box with me and my lines were
always in my cigar box she went on to
earn a Golden Globe and Emmy for the
role in 1991. she also starred on the
big screen including the film Star Trek
2 the Wrath of Khan in 1982.
standby project parabolic course to
avoid entering neutral zone I captain I
was very grateful don't get me wrong and
I really wanted to do it I mean I was
thrilled when I got Star Trek but I sort
of thought my first role would be like
body heat you know or something I didn't
know I'd be playing a Vulcan then seven
years later she appeared in Look Who's
Talking acting opposite John Travolta
has nothing to do with you you are not
his father
well I'm the closest thing that he's got
to it I felt like I had been with John a
long time and John was charming and I
thought
well maybe we can be Charming together
we're just so at home with each other
working I mean I've never been in a more
comfortable situation working with
someone we just see the humor in each
other's personalities and we go with it
which is a rare thing she is magical
that way and even this Olson's Hit It
Takes Two we might have hit this one out
of the park you and me
it was there I know it then
can't eat can't sleep
Reach for the Stars over the fence World
Series kind of thing I started out in
feature and I've gone boom boom boom
boom back and forth back and forth
I have never really been concerned about
what media it is as long as I want to
play that role and I think that that can
you know make me a better actor